[Música]
la belleza Es una maldición pensó psique
mientras miraba el acantilado Donde
había sido abandonada por su padre
había nacido con la perfección física
Tan completa que fue adorada como la
nueva Encarnación de Venus la Diosa del
amor pero Los amantes humanos de la vida
real estaban demasiado intimidados
incluso para acercarse a ella
cuando su padre pidió consejo al oráculo
de Apolo el dios de la luz la razón y la
profecía le dijeron que abandonara a su
hija en un acantilado donde se casaría
con un mal alado cruel y salvaje
sola en el Peñón sí que sentía a sefir
el viento del Oeste que la levantaba
suavemente en el aire la puso ante un
palacio
estás en casa dijo una invisible
tu marido te espera en el dormitorio
si te atreves a conocerlo era lo
suficientemente valiente se dijo sí que
a sí misma la habitación estaba tan
oscura que no podía ver a su marido pero
no lo sentía como una serpiente su piel
era suave su voz y sus maneras eran
suaves ella le preguntó quién era él
pero él dijo que esa era la única
pregunta que él nunca podría contestar
si ella lo amaba no tendría que saberlo
sus visitas continuaron noche tras noche
en poco tiempo sí que estaba embarazada
ella se regocijó pero también estaba
contrariada Cómo podía criar a su bebé
con un hombre a quien nunca había visto
esa noche sí que se acercó a su marido
Durmiente con una lámpara de aceite
lo que encontró fue al dios Cupido que
envió dioses y humanos lujuriosos unos
tras otros con los pinchazos de sus
flechas
sí que soltó su lámpara y quemó a Cupido
con aceite caliente
él dijo que había estado enamorado de sí
que desde que su celosa madre Venus le
pidió avergonzar a la joven pinchandola
con una flecha pero arrebatado por la
belleza de sique Cupido usó la flecha
para sí mismo no creía sin embargo que
los dioses y los humanos pudieran amar
como iguales al conocer su forma real la
esperanza de felicidad de ella se
desvaneció
Así que él se fue lejos
sí que se quedó desesperada hasta que la
voz invisible volvió para decirle que
era posible que ella y Cupido se amaran
como iguales
animada se dispuso a encontrarlo Pero
Venus interceptó Así que y dijo que ella
y Cupido solo podrían casarse si ella
completaba una serie de tareas
imposibles
primero sí que debía ordenar una enorme
pila de semillas en una noche
cuando ella estaba a punto de abandonar
las esperanzas una colonia de hormigas
tuvo compasión de ella y la ayudó con el
trabajo pasó con éxito la primera prueba
después sí que tuvo que traer a Venus el
vellón de la oveja dorada que tenía fama
de destripar Aventureros callejeros pero
un Dios del río le mostró cómo recoger
el vellón que las ovejas habían
enganchado sobre zarzas y ella lo logró
Finalmente sí que tuvo que viajar al
Inframundo y convencer a proserpina
reina de los muertos de poner una gota
de su belleza en una caja para Venus
una vez más la voz invisible vino a
ayudar así que
dijo que llevara pasteles para cerberus
el perro guardián del inframundo y
dinero para pagar al barquero Sharon
para transportarla por el río sticks
con su tercera y última tarea completa
sí que volvió a la tierra de los vivos
justo fuera del Palacio de Venus abrió
la caja de la belleza de proserpina con
la esperanza de guardar algo para ella
pero la caja estaba llena de sueño No de
belleza y sí que se derrumbó en el
camino
Cupido ahora recuperado de sus heridas
voló hacia su novia dormida le dijo que
se había equivocado
su audacia frente a lo desconocido
demostró que era más que su igual
Cupido le dio Así que ambrosia el néctar
de los dioses y la hizo inmortal
Poco después sí que dio a luz a su hija
La llamaron placer y ella Cupido y
psique cuyo nombre significa alma han
estado complicando la vida amorosa de la
gente desde entonces
mire estos vídeos para conocer más
historias de los mortales y dioses sus
aventuras errores castigos y recompensas
o suscríbase a nuestro canal para
conocer más mitos de todo el mundo
[Música]